wollten wir kommen zu einer ganz
besonderen runde bett was heute wir
spielen etwas auf dem river und zwar den
esl modus mit dr
die native dreh wie zander sturm ii und
gamers time und wir sind ja wir müssen
auf jeden fall taktisch spielen also die
anderen haben einige die was drauf haben
zumindest sturm
die beats kann das wirklich machen ich
kann echt vorlagen
wir müssen aufgaben aufteilen
weil ich gebe dir noch schnell eine alte
ich habe gar kein ich habe gar keine
ahnung wie jedes shops ich hab nur noch
15 blöcke besorgt euch schnell welche
bitte des shopsystems cool du musst aber
nur die sachen im inventar und dann gibt
dann drückst du drauf wenn man sich
gewohnt wie wir es heute um 18 uhr kommt
der modus andere leute ich brauche ein
paar blöcke ich brauchte ein paar blöcke
der abrüstung
ich komme aus der ersten low etwas
gehört ich wäre ja ich hab ich habe das
gold 7 sehr gut sehr gut sind
ich komme jetzt auch in die mithelfen
einer immer an eins bleiben würde ich
sagen lassen wir in der base für den
anfang oder ich hatte mir hat gewonnen
na ja auf jeden fall kann ich aber nicht
machen
ok hast du mir unter wieso aber dann
können wir die afag games hat den abriss
leute wir müssen dringend was machen für
die mitte
ich habe darunter geschossen bogen der
studie kommen zu lassen schlägt zur
raschen start und ging hier mal ein
bisschen dann könnte dann komme ich ihn
entgegen und probiert zu kicken leute
übrigens das pad wird nach achtung
stelle mich vor dem sturm bekommt er hat
mich fast der ist aber laut sturm was
ist los bin zurück von den bogen zu
holen ok
wir sollten definitiv probieren für alle
in bogen zu klären sturm ist da eben der
mitte bleiben gut verdienen ja wohl was
ihn sehr schön
ok jetzt aufwärts auf rein verstehen ich
bin glaube ich bin auch sehr schön sehr
schön inspizierte abgestoppt bringt es
zurück in die base noch mehr
ich bin okay wir brauchen jetzt dringend
an mit bogen in der mitte jetzt geht es
um die mitte in fünf minuten wird
abgebaut
nach 15 minuten
ja klar natürlich das gilt auch dafür
wenn die teams gleich gut sind das
kannst du kannst du die aufhalten
ich weiß aber wie diese dürften das eher
selten können oder was meint ihr müsst
spielte sie am steg
kommen wir kommende kommen davon
gekommen steht auf lack und hasten
schwer
unter dem bogen oder drogen hätten
diejenigen ich bin halt bis auf dem
bogen achtung
nach praktisch alter solche leute die
selber runter springen um mich zu sehr
interessant ich hab hier noch was
wir sollten uns nur die die zeit
ausnutzen
richtig viele blöcke willst du dich von
oben über die von der mitte aus über die
besten das wird nicht sie haben bogen
war es zu spät die kiste wenn ich daran
jetzt 11 4 beide runter weiter runter so
ein roter wir haben die gut gut
dominiert die mit herzen und immer
bessere schwerter für und so gehalten
werden
yahoo meine taktik war für mich immer
noch spitze haben doch besser und ich
habe das so ja ich hab jetzt aber einem
schwert und zwei von diesen teuren
die branche lockt lasst mal kurz durch
geben was was haben alle so viel grip
wir müssen mich vorbereiten also bei mir
ist halb problem ich habe auch nur die
die los zetas play
ja ich auch aber das ist glaube ich ja
wie zara ist bleibt machen aber auch zu
ich bleibe ich glaube du kommst nicht so
einfach drüber
ich glaube ja der sender werde kostet 14
grad mehr
ich habe ja oder wir schicken einen tank
von der den bogenschützen erledigt auch
das ab da sind wir halt werden wir halt
mit eisen schwert ich habe noch neun
gold wenig legt das vor uns also auf den
gang jetzt ins 13
dann sollte ich den tank machen dann
nämlich den bogen die kiste ist ein
goldfisch man trinkt nichts mehr ging es
deshalb in hochform bringt wirklich
nicht siehst mich auch obwohl ich in der
mitte nicht hochbau ist seitlich um der
will sondern dass er sich von der seite
zu unserer baseball und ballern
ja weil ein runter ja das ist die frage
ich denke dass das läuft darauf hinaus
dass wir einfach nur abwarten bis das
ding weg ist abwarten und tee trinken
zeit weg ist will costa rica mal rüber
schließen dann tue ich den bogen
doch das nimmt den eigenständigkeit
geben
ich habe schon als ich will hier auch
die beste display jüngsten wir müssen
stürmen langsamer treffen doch zusammen
karten
da kommt jemand ja genau jetzt wird eine
von uns hätten das noch gar nicht so
sonst so wir haben das jetzt die regeln
oder wir holen uns noch und damit packen
wir das feld kann man heck schreiben
diese machen die wollen sie ablenken
nicht alle rasch man nicht alle der
bogenschützen ist ja immer noch da
denn es hat ja in der rolle ich habe
keine spitzhacke und das wetter ich komm
ich kann mich halt noch die mitte ich
heute noch die mitte okay ich bin ich
runter geschlagen aber ich hab die haben
also zwei jahre kommt her komm nach komm
bitte nachkommen weg ist jetzt mich ende
gewesen
das ende während die daumen wenn wir uns
nicht alle besser
ach so herrlich waffe ziehen sie lebt
noch sie lebt noch regiert noch baby
wird auf dem weg seien leute geht den
weg aus drum hab ich auch jetzt keine
sind die so schön herumgekommen
wen hast du einen bogen dabei danke für
den 11 die screenshot von diesem
ergebnis machten alles klar
das alter kein anderer den fall dann
vorbei war sehr intensive spannung